J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So we were talking
about green chemistry.
Today we'll talk about one
aspect, the Mitsunobu
reaction, and then get on to
acids and acid derivatives.
And then we'll do that again
next lecture, more about acid
derivatives, condensations, and
some stuff about
carbohydrates, and then the last
two lectures.
Now, remember when we were
talking about green chemistry,
there were some new processes
that were desired.
There were old processes that
need improvement, and new
processes that need to be
developed, according to the
wishes of the pharmaceutical
industry.
Remember, there were six votes
for aromatic cross-coupling I
mentioned right at the end last
time.
That's how to put two benzene
rings or other aromatic rings
together, without using
haloaromatics.
We haven't talked about those
reactions, but that's their
top desire.
Then how to use aldehydes or
ketones plus ammonia and
reduction to give a chiral
amine.
Now, notice how many of these
things have to do with getting
a single enantiomer, because
that's so important in drugs,
to have a single enantiomer.
And this, notice what they want
here is to
do what nature does.
We talked before about making
glutamic acid by what's called
reductive amination, where you
have a reducing agent, NADH.
You make the imine and then
reduce it.
So four of the six
pharmaceutical companies said
that was something they would
really like to be able to do.
Or asymmetric hydrogenation of
olefins
and enamines or imines.
And notice, this is
hydrogenation of an imine,
this very reaction here.
But what they want is
asymmetric.
That is, the ability to make a
single enantiomer so you don't
have to throw half the stuff
away and do a separation.
Four voted for a greener
fluorination method.
A lot of drugs have fluorine in
them, and the reagents that
put those in are often pretty
vigorous ones.
Nitrogen chemistry, avoiding
azides, and three, avoiding
hydrazine, which is very
poisonous.
Asymmetric hydramination.
Again, asymmetric.
Greener electrophilic nitration.
We talked about electrophilic
aromatic
substitution, nitration.
But what they want is a greener
way to do it.
And the final one is asymmetric
addition of HCN.
Notice, incidentally, that four
of these eight-- half of
them-- have to do with
asymmetric synthesis, making
chiral things.
And notice that six of them, six
of the eight, have to do
with nitrogen.
Now at the end last time, we
were talking about the other
table, the one of processes that
need improving.
And in particular, something
that seems surprising to many
chemists is O activation for
nucleophilic substitution.
We've talked about that so long,
getting a halogen or a
tosylate that can be
substituted, but they want
something that's better than
that.
And noticed that three voted for
a safer and more
environmental Mitsunobu
reaction.
So let's see what the Mitsunobu
reaction is.
And you'll see that it is a type
of that second case,
activation of OH for
nucleophilic substitution.
So there's a picture of
Mitsunobu.
And in the 1960s, he invented
this reaction with a great
leaving group.
The OP plus Ph1-3 leaving group.
And so if you bring in a
nucleophile, bingo!
It's a very clean substitution
reaction, that is clean in the
sense that it gives a high
yield.
And it's very general.
Any nucleophile will work, it
seems, if it has a pKa, if
it's more acidic, than 15.
For example, a carboxylate can
get an R put on it, or the
phosphoric acid, or the imide,
or N3 minus, or most
significantly, active methylene
compounds.
So let's see what that means,
active methylene compound.
So here's a specific example
taken from Mitsunobu's paper
in the journal Synthesis to make
(S)-(-)-methylsuccinic acid.
So it's an asymmetric synthesis
to make it, and it
starts with a chiral starting
material,
(S)-(-)-ethyl lactate.
So the idea is to make the OH
into a leaving group, so let's
read through his thing and see
how he does it.
He uses the reagents 1 and 2.
Now, 1 is triphenylphosphine,
and 2 is a compound whose
acronym is DEAD, and we'll see
later what-- it's diethyl
azodicarboxylate.
So we'll see how that works.
But at any rate-- those two in
the next slide--
but for now, let's just take
that that makes that leaving
group, puts the triphenyl
phosphorus on the oxygen, with
a plus charge.
So now we've got a good leaving
group, and we want a
nucleophile to displace it.
And the nucleophile they use in
this example is ethyl
cyanoacetate.
So it's the ethyl ester of
acetic acid, but the carbon
has a cyano on it.
And that makes it an active
methylene compound.
And the reason is it has a pKa
of 13.
It's pretty acidic for a CH
bond.
Now the reason, of course, is
what you get, is an enolate,
because there's an alpha
carbonyl.
It's alpha to a carbonyl, but
it's also alpha to the CN
triple bond.
So it's doubly activated by low
LUMOs next door.
So it easily makes that anion.
So this then can be a
nucleophile that will displace
on the carbon.
So it's going to come across and
invert the carbon and make
the new bond.
And that's the first product
they want: diethyl
2-cyano-3-methyl succinate.
Now, notice they say the yield
is pretty good,
61%, right?
And notice especially that the
conditions are very mild.
These reactions started at minus
20 degrees and then just
warmed to room temperature.
It's not something that needs a
lot of heating.
On the other hand, they had to
isolate it by preparative
layer chromatography.
So that's not an easy thing to
do on a large-ish scale.
So that's certainly a painful
thing to do, to try to get--
it tends to be insoluble so you
can filter it off.
But to get the last bits of it
out, you have to do this layer
chromatography.
So that's certainly not so
great.
Notice that it says, ultimately
the optical purity
is greater than 99%.
Now, this reaction is indeed
very, very clean inversion.
So that's one of the hallmarks
of the Mitsunobu reaction.
But, in fact, it's not proved by
that 99% purity, because
you notice, at the end it was
recrystallized.
The product is recrystallized.
So even if there was a little
bit of the wrong enantiomer in
there, when you crystallize it,
you'd get only the right
enantiomer, in purifying it that
way.
So this doesn't prove it, but
it's true that it gives very,
very clean inversion, and that's
one of its main
advantages.
OK.
But notice, incidentally, that
this isn't the
product they wanted.
This is an intermediate.
And notice that there are two
chiral centers.
This one, which was 99%
inverted, and this one, which
came from the anion that did the
attacking, the active
methylene compound.
And there's no reason that that
should
be only one, right?
It could have inverted at this
stage of the anion.
That is, the anion would have
been planar because of the
conjugation with the double
bonds next door.
So wouldn't that lower the
yield?
No, because of the product
they're finally going to.
And you'll see how that is.
They hydrolyze this intermediate
to (S)-(-)-methylsuccinic
acid, which you notice is what
it is they're
trying to make up at the top.
So they were able to convert the
ester to an acid, the
other ester to an acid.
That's the reverse of a Fischer
esterification, acid and water.
And the CN triple bond also
hydrolyzes to an acid,
although it takes more work.
It was heated under reflux for
16 hours, but that converted
that one to an acid. And now you
notice this carbon isn't
chiral anymore, because it's got
two acid groups.
And even more than that, it
turns out that when you have a
situation like that, it
decarboxylates.
It loses the CO2, and the H
comes on here.
So again, it's not a chiral
carbon.
So this is the product, and the
ultimate
yield was 29% overall.
So that's not 100% reaction, but
it's very, very clean, in
terms of the product being
stereochemically pure.
And the purity, the
stereochemical purity, the
inversion, is sometimes used by
synthetic chemists when
they design a complicated
synthesis and they make an
alcohol, but it turns out not to
be the
one they want, right?
It's the wrong enantiomer.
So then they use a version of
this reaction called the
Mitsunobu Inversion.
So for example, suppose they
made this (S)-configured
alcohol, but what they really
wanted was the ()R. So what you
need to do is make that OH into
a leaving group and bring
an oxygen in from the backside
to make the other one.
So they can do this, to correct
the synthetic “mistake”, by
using these reagents
triphenylphosphine and DEAD
and acetic acids.
So the acetic acid is something
that's more acidic
than pKa 15.
It's got pKa 5, so it'll do the
trick.
So you mix these things
together, do the reaction, and
it makes the acetate in the
back.
And now that's the ester of the
alcohol you want, so all
you have to do is treat it with
acid[correction: base] and get
the inverted alcohol.
Now, how does this activation
work?
How do you do this in order to
get the great leaving group?
Well, you react
triphenylphosphine
with HOR to do that.
But they won't interact
directly.
That's, notice, -3, and in the
product it's -1,
so you're going to need an
oxidizing agent
in order to go there.
And that oxidizing agent is this
compound
number 1 up here.
Diethyl--
so it's an ethyl ester on both
ends, notice it's
symmetrical--
azodicarboxylate, DEAD.
Now, this is sort of a
complicated scheme.
And it's balanced just right so
the correct nucleophile
will attack at each step.
There are three nucleophiles
that are involved.
There's the phosphorus unshared
pair.
There's the unshared pair on an
oxygen of the alcohol.
And there's X minus that was
formed from the acid that you
put in, which is ultimately the
thing that's going to do
the displacing.
That's the nucleophile that
comes in.
So you don't want the wrong
nucleophile to be operating at
any given time.
OK.
So first, the unshared pair on
phosphorus attacks the double
bond on nitrogen, which will put
a charge on this nitrogen
here when these electrons go on
there.
What's good about having the
charge on that nitrogen?
Why would that be better than
adding to any old
N=N?
STUDENT: Resonance?
PROFESSOR: Yeah. It's got the
resonance with the carbonyl, so
it's going to make this allylic system here.
OK.
So that comes in.
And now this HX is one of these
things that has a pKa
less than 15.
So it's able, then, to protonate
this--
Remember, this is a fairly
stable anion, but it's not as
stable as X minus.
It doesn't have that low a pKa.
So this one's able to protonate
here.
Now, notice, if X attacked--
X is the anion of a pretty good
acid.
You could imagine that attacking
the phosphorus to
make a fifth bond to phosphorus.
Right?
Phosphorus has vacant
d-orbitals.
But if it did, it would come off
again, because it's a much
better anion than the anion
formed if you broke the
phosphorus-nitrogen bond.
So this is an example of it
being tuned just right.
So if the X came on it, would
just come off again.
But if the unshared pair of
oxygen goes on, then you would
get the bond formed like this.
And now that would come off
again.
The protonated oxygen is a
stronger acid
than this would be.
But if it loses the proton, then
this one is now a better
leaving group, especially if it
gets protonated.
So now we've made this thing
here.
We've made the oxygen into a
leaving group.
And notice, at the same time,
the nitrogen-nitrogen, which
originally was a double bond,
now has two hydrogens on it.
So it got reduced, right?
That is, it was the oxidizing
agent that
allowed this to happen.
And now X minus is able to do
the nucleophilic substitution,
and that's how the Mitsunobu
activation happens.
And notice that this last one
here, then, is irreversible.
Once you put the X on, this is
not a good nucleophile.
It's not going to come back on.
So this is a high yield process,
when you do that one.
But the problem is that complete
separation required
chromatography.
That was bad about it.
And at least this aspect of it
has been improved.
And it's an interesting way in
which it's been improved.
Instead of using triphenyl
phosphine, the benzene rings
of the triphenyl phosphine, some
of them, are attached to
a polymer, right, like that.
So that means if you have a
polymer bead that holds this
reagent, at the end, you don't
have to do the chromatography
in order to separate your
product from the triphenyl
phosphine oxide.
You just have to filter it,
because it's attached to a
solid polymer.
But what disturbs the green
chemists about this otherwise
handy reaction is that your goal
is to eliminate water
between HX and ROH.
But in order to do that, you
generate byproducts that have
a molecular weight of 450.
So this is what's called atom
inefficient.
You generate lots of waste for
the way to the
molecule you generate.
Now, we're going to be talking
about oxidation of aldehydes
and alcohols.
We have talked about some of
them already.
But it's nice to do those in a
green way, too.
And in fact, we already talked
about such a
reaction last semester.
It was one of the first
oxidations of an aldehyde that
was studied, which was the oil
of bitter almonds.
You remember what was special
about this sample?
When you turned it over, it
turned out that this aldehyde
was in fact mostly solid.
It had converted spontaneously
to benzoic acid without adding
any chromium, manganese, or
anything like that.
You got benzoic acid just by
reacting it with oxygen.
So there could hardly be a
cleaner, greener process.
So the air oxidation of
benzaldehyde is a process that
I think we've mentioned before,
but I'll
talk about it again.
So it's a free-radical chain
reaction.
You have some radical which
pulls the hydrogen away from
the aldehyde, which generates
this acyl radical.
But the acyl radical can now
attack oxygen to form a new
bond, and a single bond to
oxygen, which itself is now a
radical, which is the X. So X
comes back and takes the
hydrogen from the other, and the
product, then, is not
benzoic acid, but peroxybenzoic
acid.
So that's what you would expect
to get at first.
But in fact, it might be fun for
you just to review free
radical chain reactions by
writing this thing in one of
those cyclic diagrams as to what
comes in, where the
radicals are, what comes out.
That would be a good exercise.
So this is the initial product.
But this itself as an oxidizing
agent.
It's got this weak oxygen-oxygen
bond, a low
LUMO, which is a little bit like
using a
halogen-halogen bond.
So it also is like an alcohol.
So it can form a hemiketal by
attacking the carbonyl.
So here's the group that
attacked, here's the new bond,
and we have OH.
So it's like a hemiketal, except
it's peroxy.
And now notice that it's
converted what would have been
an OH into an O with a leaving
group.
If this had just been a regular
old hydrate of the
aldehyde, there would be OH
here.
But now we have O with a leaving
group.
So a base can pull off the
proton, the electrons come in
to make a double bond, these
leave, and now you have
benzoic acid and benzoate, which
is a base that can do
that reaction next time.
So what could be a more
efficient reaction?
All you do is expose
benzaldehyde to oxygen, and it
becomes benzoic acid.
So there's a very green
oxidation reaction.
You can see Section 18.12, which
talks about this.
But last year when I was talking
about this subject, we
had a seminar from a professor
at Weizmann Institute, David
Milstein, who talked about
devising catalysts for greener
operations.
And I thought this one was a
very interesting one.
So this is a ruthenium catalyst,
and it has on it
carbon monoxide and hydrogen,
and then this funny ligand.
It's a pyridine, benzene with
the nitrogen in it, with
two groups, CH2 here, CH2, and
it has a nitrogen, diethylamine,
on this end, and
di-t-butylphosphine
on the other end.
So it has three things with
unshared pairs, phosphorus,
nitrogen, and nitrogen, that can
mix with the orbitals of
the ruthenium to make this
complex.
Now, I've colored two of the
hydrogens here green, because
they can come off.
You could lose H2, having lost
those two hydrogens, notice,
or you can add H2 and come back
again.
Now, how does that happen?
Well, notice that this stuff
here, the nitrogen plus charge
with an extra bond here, going
to this kind of ring, is a
little bit reminiscent of what
we saw before with
NAD plus and NADH.
That this is a nucleophilic
aromatic substitution, the
start of it.
So the H minus adds here.
These go on to the nitrogen.
So you have a ring like that
one, and H attached.
But the H minus can come off
again, and be given to
something else.
So this is closely balanced,
right?
This one has the advantage of
being aromatic.
having a new bond, and not
being charged.
So being closely balanced, it
can go back and forth.
So the same way that NADH in
nature can function as both an
oxidizing and a reducing agent,
going one way or
another, you could imagine that
a thing like this can go
back and forth.
So lose the H plus and go back,
as far as the stability
in this part of it goes.
But there's a problem.
The H could be thought of as H
minus, because
it's bonded to a metal.
So the electrons are mostly on
the more
electronegative hydrogen.
But it can't reach to that
position, so you can't do that
kind of thing.
But what it can reach is the
hydrogen here, if we change
the conformation of the thing a
little bit.
So you can imagine that the
hydride attacks this hydrogen,
which loses these electrons to
make that bond.
And that's helped by the fact
that these electrons then get
stabilized by moving on to the
positive nitrogen.
Right?
So this type of effect is what
allows this to go back and
forth in either direction.
But we're most interested in the
direction going up.
So let's redraw that thing and
look at what happens if
there's an alcohol.
So an alcohol comes in, and its
unshared pair makes a bond
to the ruthenium, and now it's O
plus.
Now we can have the hydride--
notice it's H--
Wait a second, have I done the
right thing here?
Oh no.
What we're doing is using the
unshared pair of nitrogen.
This is not like hydride.
I said the wrong thing.
This is a proton.
The electrons are going away
from this hydrogen.
So the proton is able to go on
here, to
generate the N plus again.
And now notice, at the same
time, that that alcohol that
came on had two H's that I drew
explicitly.
The one down here is the one I'm
interested in, because
it's near the ruthenium.
And now if this were O minus--
and notice, in a sense, it is O
minus, because it's bonded
to a metal--
then the electrons of the O
minus, these electrons, can
make a double bond here, giving
hydride.
A hydride can attack the
ruthenium.
Like that.
So notice what the product of
this is, then.
At the top, we get a carbonyl
group, and the thing we have
at the bottom is this, which can
start the whole process
over again by giving off H2.
So what has this whole catalytic
cycle accomplished?
You've brought in an alcohol,
and you removed from it these
two hydrogens as H2.
So it's an oxidation of the
alcohol, not by bringing in
oxygen and making water, but by
giving off H2.
So now in this particular
reaction, there's another
oxidation removing H2 from a
different alcohol.
Notice the product is an
aldehyde, but in water it will
form a diol.
So it could be the alcohol that
comes in, and you remove
another H2 from it, which gives
then a carboxylic acid.
Plus you're oxidizing another
alcohol, and have CO coupling,
and you get--
Have I done this right?
I think I counted wrong here.
I think I wrote this wrong.
I don't think you oxidize that
alcohol.
But at any rate, it couples to
give the ester.
I think that should be two H2s
there.
I'll correct that.
But this happens in the presence
of this catalyst with
no other activation.
So what comes in is the alcohol,
what comes out is two
moles of hydrogen and the ester.
Right?
A very clean process.
So here's a table taken from
Milstein's paper, and you can
see, with several different
alcohols, he was able to get
high conversions, higher than
90, up to 99%, very high
yields of the ester, and only a
little bit of the aldehyde.
Most of it got oxidized.
Let's look at the
thermochemistry of this.
And again, I think that should
be two H2s.
So if you look at the heat of
formation of ethanol and the
heat of formation of the ester
that's the product from that,
and hydrogen has a free energy
of zero, so the two hydrogens
don't count.
But if we add it together, this
reaction is endothermic
by seventeen kilocalories per
mole.
So it's way uphill.
You'd think the equilibrium
constant would be very
unfavorable.
What makes it possible for this
to happen catalytically?
We're not putting in something
that's a strong reagent that
makes one of these very
reactive, and then it can
react with the other things.
We're just putting the alcohol
in.
And to have the alcohol come in,
and ester come out, and
everything stay the same
otherwise with the catalyst,
you have to go uphill in energy
by 17 kilocalories per
mole, which sounds very tough.
But there are two things that
make this good.
You start with two molecules,
and you form three molecules.
Two H2 and the ester.
Again, I counted wrong here.
So by making more molecules, you
make
more entropy available.
And furthermore, this is
especially helped because you
make those two hydrogen gas
molecules, and you can remove
those from the solution.
So notice how this was done.
It was done, in one case, under
a flow of argon to sweep
the hydrogen gas out.
And in the other case, the
toluene solution was refluxed,
which again, the solvent pushes
the other gas out.
So at low pressure of hydrogen,
it's possible to do
this spontaneously.
So that's an important type of
analysis to do on a catalytic
cycle that you've proposed, as
to whether, in fact, it could
be thermodynamically allowed.
They also were able to make
amines that way, starting with
alcohols make an imine by
reacting with ammonia.
So alcohol plus ammonia gives an
amine.
And also, incidentally, an
imine.
So probably, it's the same kind
of thing as before.
The alcohol gets oxidized to an
aldehyde, but in the
presence of the nitrogen, it
forms the imine, the CN double
bond, and then that gets reduced
by the hydrogen that's
there in order to give the
amine.
But again, these are very high
yield reactions.
When you look at a synthetic
paper and a table in it, it's
important to look at two
different kinds of yields.
The normal yields given here are
an analyzed by gas
chromatography to figure out how
much was in there.
But what you're really
interested in is what you can
put in a bottle as a pure form,
right?
So the yields in parentheses are
isolated products.
So sometimes they're very good,
compared to the gas
chromatography yield.
But in this particular case,
it's hard to separate, and you
only get half as much out to
sell to your neighbor as you
had analyzed by GC.
So you can also make imines and
amides and so on with
these catalysts.
So that's an interesting
development which seems to
address, if not to solve
perhaps, some of these
problems that the pharmaceutical
industry
identified.
Now, we've been talking in these
last examples of green
chemistry about acids and acid
derivatives.
So let's talk about them a
little more systematically.
First, the acidity of our CO2H,
of a carboxylic acid.
You remember that the pKa of a
normal carboxylic acid is
between 4 and 5, like butyric
acid is 4.8.
Now let's look at the effect of
putting
a chlorine in there.
So if you put the chlorine in on
the terminal carbon, it
hardly changes the pKa at all,
just by 0.3 units.
If you move it a little bit
closer to the carboxylic acid,
it's 4.1, and if you move it as
close as possible to the
carboxylic acid, now it makes a
real difference.
2.8.
What is it that the chlorine is
doing?
STUDENT: It's electron
withdrawing?
PROFESSOR: So it's electron
withdrawing.
And how does that help?
STUDENT: It makes the H come
off.
PROFESSOR: And how does it make
the H come off?
STUDENT: By reducing the bond
strength.
PROFESSOR: Why does it reduce
the bond strength?
You know, actually, I bet that's
not true.
I bet it doesn't reduce the bond
strength.
The bond strength is the kind of
thing that Professor
Ellison talked about last time.
Breaking a bond to give two--
people laugh already.
I just mentioned his name, and
they laugh.
OK?
You break the body and you get
two free-radicals.
I don't know the results, but my
strong suspicion is that
chlorine hardly affects that at
all.
What it affects is dissociation
as an acid.
So what is it that the chlorine
is stabilizing?
STUDENT: The LUMO?
PROFESSOR: It affects the anion,
right?
So the electron withdrawal by
the chlorine makes the
nearby region of the molecule a
better place to put more
electrons, as in the anion
rather
than the neutral molecule.
So this inductive effect of the
chlorine works, but only
in the vicinity of the chlorine.
It dies away as you get further
and
further from the chlorine.
So this is so-called inductive
effect.
And it's not very big if you're
far away, but if you
get pretty close, it can be big.
Now let's just see this
inductive effect, if it could
be quantitatively reasonable.
If the withdrawal by the
chlorine stabilizes the
negative charge by a certain
amount of energy, then the
equilibrium becomes easier by
that amount of energy, and
that energy difference would
appear in the exponent for the
equilibrium constant.
Remember, 10 to the 2/3 delta H.
So it would make a certain
energy effect in the exponent,
and if you put two of them in,
you'd make twice that change
in the exponent, if it were
simple.
And that means results would be
multiplicative, because
when you add things in an
exponent, that means you
multiply the numbers.
OK.
So let's look at acetic acid,
chloroacetic acid, dichloro
and trichloroacetic acid, and
see whether this inductive
effect of the chlorine is
additive in energy, therefore
multiplicative in equilibrium
constant.
Or if you do the log of the
equilibrium constant, then it
would be additive, because it's
up in the exponent.
So notice, here it's 4.8.
Same as here.
Here it's 2.9, same as here.
So it's the same kind of effect.
But let's look at the values
here, not at the values
themselves, but at the
difference.
How much difference did that
first chlorine make?
It made a difference of 1.9 pKa
units.
Now, if the second one had the
same effect on the energy of
an anion, that would also be
1.9.
It's actually 1.6.
Not quite as big.
And the third one hardly makes
any difference at all.
It's only 0.6.
I mean, it's substantial, but
it's not anything like the
first ones.
And the reason is that once the
anion is already
stabilized, it gets harder and
harder to
withdraw subsequent electrons.
One chlorine withdraws a certain
amount.
The next chlorine doesn't have
as much to withdraw, so it
can't do quite as good a job.
The third one does a much poorer
job.
But fluorine is better than
chlorine, and trifluoroacetic
acid is quite a strong acid.
It's got a negative pKa.
So that's the inductive effect.
And now we might wonder, what is
it that makes the
carboxylic acid acidic
altogether, ignoring these
additional inductive effects?
So Paul Rablen from Swarthmore
College published a paper in
the Journal of the American
Chemical Society in 2000 that
had an interesting analysis of
this.
And I put it on because
Professor Ellison is such a
big advocate of resonance
structures, as you saw last
time, rather than molecular
orbital theory.
So this is an interesting
analysis, in terms of
resonance structures.
Now, what he did is do very good
calculations, but
calculations in the gas phase,
not in a solvent, of what the
equilibrium constant should be,
or what the energy
involved should be in
transferring a proton from an
alcohol to a carboxylic acid.
So you get the anion of the
alcohol, and the protonated
carboxylic acid.
And now, the carboxylic acids
are called acids because they
give their protons to bases.
So this reaction lies to the
left.
And to go to the right is uphill
by almost 28
kilocalories per mole in the gas
phase.
Now, the difference in pKa, the
pKa of an
alcohol is about 16.
The pKa of a carboxylic acid is
about 5.
So the difference in pKa is
about 11.
Therefore, you would expect the
equilibrium constant at
room temperature to be about 4/3
of that.
So it should be about 15
kilocalories per mole.
But notice that pKas are defined
in water, so it must
be that the solvent makes an
enormous effect, right?
It reduces this to about half of
its value, from close to 30
to 15, by making it easier to go
to the right.
Only 15 kilocalories uphill,
instead of 30
kilocalories uphill.
Why?
It could be because this one has
a much more concentrated
negative charge, so it gets more
effectively solvated by
the water, compared to this one,
which helps drive the
reaction on the left.
But anyhow, that's a secondary
consideration, because we're
just looking, as Rablen did, at
the
molecules in the gas phase.
OK.
So it's 28 kilocalories uphill
to do that.
Now, what's the reason?
Why does it want to go that way?
Well, we're tempted to say
resonance.
That's certainly what Ellison
would have said.
You have two resonance
structures of this anion, and
only one resonance structure
that's
reasonable on the right.
Can you think of any other
reason that it might be good
to go to the left?
Anything else that makes that a
better anion, compared to
this anion other than resonance?
Any idea?
These are Hs's.
Incidentally.
CH3.
And here's HCOO minus.
If resonance weren't a factor,
would you expect
these to be the same?
Would you expect the equilibrium
constant to be one?
Amy?
STUDENT: Well, no, because the
pi* is helping out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The pi-star helping out is the
molecular orbital way of
saying there's resonance.
That's how they do it.
So that, in fact, is the same
thing.
But is there anything else that
would tend to
make it go that way?
STUDENT: Having the other oxygen
up there?
PROFESSOR: And how would the
oxygen help?
STUDENT: Inductive effect?
PROFESSOR: So it could be an
inductive effect.
But notice this oxygen is closer
than the chlorine that
was making the difference
before.
The chlorine was out on the next
carbon.
So you could also have an
inductive
effect due to the oxygen.
Now, notice that it's a double
bond.
So it's an interesting question
whether you count the
oxygen once or count it twice.
So for purposes of this paper,
Rablen hypothesized that you
count the oxygen twice.
So now we have resonance and
inductive effects, and we can
do some numerology about these,
about how important
resonance structures are.
OK.
So notice that this 27.0
kilocalories is due to loss of
resonance and to loss of two
inductive effects for oxygen,
if you're supposed to count it
twice with the double bond.
Now, let's look at this one,
where instead of using
alcohol, we used the ketone and
a
protonated acid here.
So instead of the anion, it's
protonated now.
And now we transfer the proton
from here to the ketone--
or it's the aldehyde, actually.
these are hydrogens.
So we make the protonated ketone
and
the carboxylic acid.
Now, here the reaction lies to
the right.
It's exothermic by 6.2
kilocalories per
mole in the gas phase.
Now, which side would resonance
favor?
Debbie, can you help us out?
Would you draw resonance
structures of this?
STUDENT: You could.
PROFESSOR: You could.
You could use the unshared pair
on the OH, and it would
be stabilized by the pi*,
but that would require
separation of charge, and
Ellison told us we don't want to
do that.
How about on the left?
Any resonance structures there?
STUDENT: Yes.
Because of the positive charge?
PROFESSOR: Speak up.
STUDENT: Because of the positive
charge.
PROFESSOR: Now you could draw a
double bond here
and a single bond there and put
the charge on the bottom.
And you're not separating
charge, you're
just moving the charge.
So here you have good resonance.
Here on the right you don't have
reasonable resonance.
On this one you had resonance on
the left
and not on the right.
So now--
or no, pardon.
In both cases, we had resonance
on the left.
OK.
So resonance is going to favor
the left and cause you to go
uphill, in either case.
Now, how about the inductive
effect?
How about the oxygen?
Let's try somebody else here.
Chris, which side is favored by
the inductive effect?
In the top, the inductive effect
favored the left,
because we had two bonds to
oxygen withdrawing electrons,
stabilizing in the anion, right?
Now how about in this case, when
we have two bonds here?
STUDENT: Favors the right.
PROFESSOR: If it stabilizes the
anion, the
argument is, it destabilizes the
cation.
So it's the same deal.
Except now... the same resonance
that would cause it to go
uphill to the right, but the
oxygen now makes it
go down[correction: up] to the
left.
Now, how many oxygens did we
have?
This time the difference between
this and this
is just this bond.
So it's not a question of
counting one or two.
There's only one bond there.
So that's one inductive effect
of oxygen.
Now we have two equations and
two unknowns.
We have the resonance effect,
which is the same direction in
both cases, and the inductive
effect, which is in opposite
directions and twice as strong,
in one case.
So if we take the difference of
these two, minus this one,
we get plus 34.1 is three of the
oxygen inductive effect.
So the oxygen inductive effect
is 11.4 kilocalories per mole.
And once we have that, we can
plug back in to see how big
the resonance effect is.
It's 4.8.
And now, from this point of
view, if we look in the top
case of that 30 kilocalories per
mole going uphill, only 5
of it was due to resonance.
By far and away, the dominant
effect is
the inductive effect.
Only 20% of the special acidity
of the carboxylic acid
is due to resonance from this
viewpoint.
Now, you may buy this resonance
argument, and you may not.
I'm personally skeptical.
But one way or the other, it
would be good to check it.
So Rablen checked it.
He did this one with carbonic
acid, the
anion of carbonic acid.
And now that's plus 37.3.
Now, what does it involve?
Here's the anion, which is
stabilized by resonance, as
this one was.
And there's no resonance
involved in this one, because
it has the hydrogen on it.
So it has resonance, the same as
the others.
How about inductive effect?
Compared to this, how many
oxygens are
stabilizg in this O minus?
Matt?
STUDENT: I can count three.
PROFESSOR: Count three.
If you count double bond twice,
which is the rules he
set, then you have three.
So that's O inductive times
three.
Now let's put that together.
So we have O inductive times 3.
That's 34.2.
And the resonance is 4.8, is 39.
Not bad.
So we can try another one.
Here we do the analog of what we
did here, put a proton on.
And now we have no resonance on
the right.
We have resonance on the left.
How many resonance structures in
addition to
the original structure?
STUDENT: Two?
PROFESSOR: Chris? You can draw
the double bond here.
That's what we did in that case.
But you can also draw the double
bond over here.
So there should be resonance
times two.
And that should favor the left,
make it uphill.
But also, you're going to have
oxygens destabilizing this
cation, two oxygens
destabilizing that cation.
And if you put those together,
it's minus 13.2,
and observed is 11.
So there are people who think
this, right?
I personally don't like this
kind of argument so much,
because I don't think it comes
down to really the
physics of the thing.
It comes to whether you count a
double bond as two bonds and
things like that.
Which, it works out.
So there are people who talk
about this thing.
And from that point of view,
resonance isn't as important
to making acids acidic as
inductive effect is.
So the inductive effect is
certainly important.
Now, making acids by oxidation
and reduction.
And we've talked about these
things.
Oxidizing an alcohol with
chromium, oxidizing--
and remember, on the way, you
get an aldehyde, so you can
also oxidize aldehydes.
And you can do it with chromium.
I put potassium permanganate in
here.
We also talked about oxidizing
double bonds with ozone and
then hydrogen peroxide to get
carboxylic acids.
There's one different type of
oxidation that we haven't
talked about yet which is
mentioned in the Jones
textbook here, which is alkyl
groups attached to a benzene
ring can be oxidized by
permanganate at 100 degrees to
make carboxylic acids, as well.
Now, you can also make
carboxylic acids by reduction.
Of course, the carbon in a
carboxylic acid is pretty much
oxidized, right?
But there are more oxidized
things, like CO2.
So if you had CO2, what would
you react it with in order to
form a carbon-carbon bond to
make a carboxylic acid?
What kind of reagent?
What would attack the carbon of
CO2?
High HOMO or low LUMO?
What would make CO2 double bond
double bond?
What would make it reactive?
Suppose it were just a single
double bond.
What makes it reactive?
The pi*, right?
The low LUMO.
So you want a high HOMO.
It's like the things we talked
about with alcohols, right,
where you could have a ketone,
react it with R minus, react
it with H minus, to go on, and
in this case that would be a
reduction of the central carbon,
and would form a
carboxylic acid.
So you can do that kind of
thing, too.
You can also react carboxylic
acids with alkyl lithium, or
hydride compounds.
So for example, you could react
a generic carboxylic
acid here with alkyl lithium.
What do you think the product
is?
Alkyl lithium is like R minus,
right?
It's a high HOMO on the R, the R
lithium bond.
So what will it attack?
Mary?
STUDENT: Is it addition at the
carbon?
PROFESSOR: Addition to what?
STUDENT: To the carbony pi*.
PROFESSOR: To the cabonyl right.
That's what I was trying to
trick you into saying.
In fact it reacts in another
way. What else does a high HOMO
do, besides make something a
nucleophile?
It makes it a base. And here we
have and acid.
So in fact the easy thing to
react with is the proton.
That's easier to access than the
carbonyl
Oops! I'm sorry I've talked too
long.
Thanks for your patience.